hi everyone yeah so great to be here in
this design hope and in this intro for
with this new PI data it's great to see
that it's coming along so so well so
just as a sort of remark for the people
who have been at the last PI data
Amsterdam meetup this is going to be
basically a recap of what we did there
as well so don't I won't feel offended
if you decide to say uh in that case I
might want to go to the other talk
instead I see one person perfect so just
quick quick show of your hands before we
actually get started who of you works
with machine learning on a let's say
daily or regular weekly basis okay who
have you put models into production that
make decisions about people that's a
couple a couple okay
so that's also always something that
frightens me because if you've been
around for quite a while in this field
you've seen models do stupid things and
there's a specific category of doing
stupid things namely when there's
unfairness at play that I think is
especially risky and we need to get
better at as a field of dealing with and
this this image might be familiar has
been all over the media at some point a
couple a couple of years ago this is
screenshots from a system called compass
and this system basically tried to
assess the rate of reoffended criminals
you can sort of see some all things on
this picture so basically we we compare
the two people on the Left here and we
compare the people on the right here and
this person here who had two armed
robberies one attempted robberies and
the grand thefts as a low risk of
reoffending next to him with four juvie
misdemeanors just basically boys being
boys has an extremely high risk and we
see something very similar on the right
as well
one petty theft like shoplifting
extremely or medium risk but domestic
violence AGG of
results drug trafficking grand theft
basically a very low risk and this is
kind of scary and figuring out that your
model is doing these kinds of things can
can be hard but it can be even harder to
figure out what we can do to stop our
models from doing this all the things
that I'm gonna discuss with you today
are implemented already in this library
called circuit Lego you might have heard
of it if you were went to Vincent's talk
earlier today there's basically a
library containing some of the things me
and my colleague Vincent used often in
machine learning projects we basically
just bundled them and make them more
easily accessible if you go to the
literature and see what people are doing
about making mobiles more fair you sort
of see three major types of mitigations
these mitigations can be summarized as
data Tobias saying using Ferrer models
or post-processing results of your
models all of their strengths and
weaknesses but if you take a bit of a
step back and think about like the
packages that we use on a regular basis
in particulars I could learn you can see
that the data dividing is basically a
certain type of transformer and a Ferrer
model is basically a certain type of
predictor that we might want to use if
you want to do post processing and maybe
we can use something called meta
estimators to do this but first I like
working a whole lot and sort of the main
adagio dairy is always measured before
your cut so let's discuss how we can
measure whether our models are doing
something that's reasonable or or doing
something that's unfair one of the main
measures so we need to be able to
measure this and we need to be able to
measure fairness between decisions we
make between two subgroups in this case
Group A and Group B and one of the main
measures that you can find is something
called demographic parity what
demographic parity says is that the
probability of predicting a positive
outcome should be equal between the two
groups if that's true then you have
demographic parity so probability of Y
had B given that Zetas zero
we're said is a binary sensitive
attributes should be the same as the
probability of Y hat being one given set
being equal to one so in both two groups
we have for positive predictions and on
first instinct this seems fair right you
have the same amount of people being
predicted as positive classes in both
groups there's some issues though
because what we could happen have
happened is that in our group a we
accept random people and in our group B
we accept qualified people this can in
in in in essence be a good demographic
parity classifier for example but I mean
you could argue that it's not fair and
also if the base rates like the base
rates of Y being equal to 1 in our
groups are different this demographic
priority measure doesn't allow having a
perfect classifier because it will try
to force them to be the same so instead
something that's a bit nicer to use I
think is equal opportunity and this adds
basically another condition to our
probability and it is the probability of
predicting a 1 for both groups should be
the same given that the true Y is also a
1 so given that I am someone who pays
back there alone I am going I have the
same chance of being admitted alone
depending not dependent on my sensitive
attributes given that I am someone who
is not likely to reoffended if attribute
does not matter in the decision of what
I'm going to be offender or not and it
basically looks something like this
so in the in the dotted line we have our
true positives and in the black dotted
line we have our predicted positives and
we see that in both groups 3 out of 5
true positives are predicted as true
positives and therefore or two out of
three two out of four are predicted as
two positives and therefore they are
equally opportune
so this is a constraint in essence this
should be the same but it's quite easy
to turn it into a metric by taking the
ratio between them and that's a number
somewhere between zero and one and you
can use it as a metric in whatever you
want so inside of learn let's just try
and implement this since I could learn
how do we typically build metrics Oh
take a function that has Y true Y hats
and it gives us back a score and I'm
that's kind of problematic right because
we're missing something here we don't
have access to our sensitive attribute
so how are we able to score thankfully
there's also something called a score
this is a slightly different function
but it takes the classifier the X and
the y and then as long as our sensitive
attribute is in X and we can use it in
our metric to see if our classifiers
fair but I see some of you thinking wait
sensitive attribute in X that doesn't
sound like a good idea if you want
fairness right then we're explicitly
telling our model what sensitive
attribute is and that's correct but the
main sort of trick you need to be aware
of here is that this classifier that
I've drawn on the screen doesn't have to
be a single model it can be a pipeline
so what if the first step of this
pipeline would be to drop our sensitive
attribute the scorer still works on the
entire pipeline so sensitive attributes
are going to be an X there's never going
to be shown to the actual classifier
which is therefore unaware of it and now
we can sort of have this entire thing
working we can use this for for equal
opportunity for demographic parity or
whatever other kind of metric you can
use this is generalizable to maybe maybe
consistency over time in time series
there's quite a few cases where you
could use something like this now that
we can measure we can up yeah so
basically code wise it looks something
like this for example this p percent
score that's the demographic parity
ratio turn it into a function that takes
a column of the sensitive attribute that
we want to compare
TRACON and then we return a
implementation version of that that
takes the the estimator the X and the y
it just does the math on the ratios and
gives you back the result in a pipeline
looks something like this we start with
a Coulomb dropper we do whatever we want
in the middle we can do I don't know our
categorical encoding is your standard
scaling and missing values and stuff we
end with logistic regression and if we
can put that in a grid search supply bow
for accuracy score and our P percent
scores metric that we want to use and we
can use this to benchmark our models so
what I ended up doing is I put this the
compressed data that was subpoenaed at
some point inside this logistic
regression and posted the results and
what it basically says is it's about 70%
accurate in predicting whether someone's
going to offend and the equal
opportunity score on gender is about 82
and on race about 0.7 8 so not great and
that's definitely also what was found in
subsequent investigations of this so
this is something we call fairness for
unawareness basically we just remove the
sensitive attributes we put our
blindfolds on and say yeah this is fair
and we can quite easily see that that's
not the case and for more complex models
it's going to be even worse so that
brings us to our first mitigation step
and this is a bit of a linear algebra
trick what we're going to try and do is
when we have these two features feature
one a feature two or feature one is our
protected
sensitive attributes what we're going to
try and do is remove all the information
that is joint between feature 1 and
feature two the idea being that if we
can't say anything about our protected
attribute based on our other attributes
and we remove our projected attributes
from the model it should not be able to
be unfair because we just remove all the
sensitive information from it and what
we how we implemented this is basically
as a modification of the gram-schmidt
process which is in an orthogonalization
pro
for effector spaces so we take the
projection of future 2 on our production
projected feature and then subtract that
trijet projection from feature 2 and it
basically means that the features are in
the end going to be orthogonal to each
other and therefore should not share any
information and should therefore be more
fair caveats only linear right no no
higher-order effects no interaction
effects so it's definitely not great
let's do this it's a try
encode that looks something like this so
this is going to be a custom transformer
in scikit-learn so we make a class
information filter we inherit nicely
from from the basis that scikit-learn
offers us and in our initialization
function we basically tell it this is
our sensitive column that we want to
filter out from the data set inside the
fit we apply this modified gram-schmidt
process to remove these projections and
we calculate the projection matrix from
the unfair representation into the fair
representation we store that so that we
can use it in transform then once again
to see to compute new mate from new
matrixes the more fair version if we
benchmark this we get quite a reasonable
improvement we see that the accuracy
goes down by a percent but the equal
opportunity score on gender and on race
goes up quite quite a lot especially
because we're using only a simple
logistic regression the linear removal
of features linear fairness the biasing
helps here but it's still more great and
we might want to be able to do better so
what can we do next well we could also
say is that we could change our model in
a normal logistic regression we try to
optimize something like this we maximize
the log likelihood of the of the
outcomes given our parameters and our
data
but what we actually want to do if we
have such a situation we want to
optimize this likelihood subject to some
fairness constraint being hired and a
value that we have can't decide upon and
we've seen some measures of fairness
rights we've seen this demographic
priority in this Equal Opportunity score
which we should be able to basically
just plug in here and say that that
ratio should be hired in some variable C
all right end point time all right n
point eight five the problem though is
that when we try to do that well we'll
find out is that these these measures
are rather unfit for direct optimization
because they are only dependent on the
actual decision and lots of decision
probabilities you get quite large saddle
points in the optimization process also
the constraints themselves are not
convex which makes them just rather hard
to optimize in general so we might need
a way in which we can approximate the
constraint it turns out that that is
reasonably doable for both demographic
parity and equal opportunity by taking
the covariance between our sensitive
attributes and the distance to the
decision boundary for specific
observations so that's basically what
we're trying to do here we treat that I
take the D means sensitive attributes of
a user
we take them times and we take the
covariance between this and take the
transpose X so the prediction that we
made for the user and for all the so the
average for all the users should be
below a certain positive and above a
certain negative constraint value turns
out this is convex and therefore
relatively easily solvable so then we
come to how do we actually solve these
complex problems well there's sort of
three main approaches here use standard
silver formulations like L P or Q P
problems there is a bunch of
off-the-shelf implementations for this
you can basically pip install them and
be merry on your way something that
isn't so nice about them though is that
the solvers take very specific formats
and how they want
you supply them a problem and that
format can be quite far away from what
you used to typing if you're just doing
math and Python right you use the typing
numpy and basically being flexible and
whatever you want to do
and these solvers are not gonna just
accept that so what else could we do
well roll your own solver of course that
doesn't sound great idea right you kind
of want to build on the shoulders of
giants and sort of use all the
optimizations they made to solve these
problems quickly and efficiently so what
I ended up using is use a convex
modeling language and you can sort of
see a complex modeling language as a
compiler for convex problems where you
plug in a bit of numpy or numpy like
code and it will decide based on some
heuristics what the best solver there is
that it can use and how to translate
your code into a formulation that that
solver will understand and that sort of
has the for me at least the best of both
worlds encode that looks something like
this so this is the sole function from
one of these fair classifiers that you
opportunity know the demographic parity
classifier I think and you can sort of
see in the beginning that we're making
just a bunch of variables like number of
observations and features we define our
decision variable the theta the
parameters of a model that we want to
learn and the next term is basically
just the log likelihood of our model
given our decision variables we apply
some regularization on dance and then we
compute this decision boundary
covariance our constraints the thing
that we want to set a constraint on and
then any API that has a problem that
solve is always good in my book so we
basically just call problem will solve
on our maximization of log likelihood
with our constraints and we store the
coefficients and the intercept onself of
Gothel intercept this we plug into the
rest of a circuit learn estimator with a
fit and predict and this basically gives
us a nice
constraining classifier in usage it
looks something like this
we can import an equal-opportunity
classifier supplied to it which are
sensitive columns and what the threshold
of our covariance should be and if you
supply different of these covariance
thresholds you will sort of see that
this that covariance threshold gets
larger the fairness of our mobile will
go down and the accuracy will go up and
there's somewhere a trade-off here and
that's up to you to make so - you to
decide what you think is a good point
here depending on your use case and the
business you're in I'm not sure which
exact covariance special I ended up
using here but we once again see that
the accuracy score from Walla only went
down by a bit but both the equal
opportunity scores have improved by
quite a lot so this tends to work so
what if what if we don't have access to
our model right sometimes you end up in
a situation where you have a fear that
you did you get a score supplied maybe
from some third party and you're not
sure whether that's course fair annulled
and you're sort of [ __ ] out of luck
right well maybe but maybe you can also
do some post-processing because if you
think about it if you plop a ROC curve
of your model for different thresholds
what you see is the false positive rate
and the two poles different that's where
you get back right and we just defined
equal opportunity to be a model where
the true positive rates of the both the
groups are the same so what we normally
end up doing for a model is if we plot
thresholds versus true positive rate
typically we set a certain threshold for
both our groups by default point five
but what we could do if they simply read
from this graph the true positive rate
that we want and select two different
thresholds for each of our sub groups
nothing necessarily wrong with it and
then we can basically guarantee that we
can have a an equally opportune
classifier
even though we don't have access to the
model itself and so I could learn we
have to do this using method estimators
and what does it matter estimator it's
basically a wrapper around an already
existing one
so we're normal estimators have
something like predicts fit and predict
probabilities and what we'll do is we'll
create a class around this that takes
one of these estimators and basically
shuffles the internals around a bit so
when we call fit what we're going to do
is we're going to basically calculate
this ROC curve and decide for each of
our subgroups what are the thresholds
that we should take to get these true
positive rates that we want and then
when we call the predicts on a meta
estimator what we'll actually do is we
won't use the original predictor for
estimator we use predict proba and
compare like in conjunction with our
sensitive attributes and the thresholds
that we computed in a fit we can then
give back should this be a true or a
false reclassified instance once again
in code equal opportunity classifier in
our initialization we start with taking
a classifier this is just a base
estimator like a logistic regression or
a random forest classifier or whatever
you want it to be and in our fit we try
to fit that we get the predict robot on
that data and we try to compute the
thresholds based on our sensitive
attributes and our desire to pose
different in the predict we basically
just do the regular predict probe ah of
our internal classifier we use our
thresholds and we say if our Y had to
never bigger than these thresholds for
the sensitive attributes then we treat
it as positive otherwise as a negative
and I think this is oh yeah I yeah this
implementation was kind of last minute
so this only works on one attribute at a
time so in this case I just picked the
equal opportunity score for gender I
only did it for gender and we can see
that our empirical opportunity score for
gender is then also very close to one
which is kind of what we would expect of
course it's not a it's not a perfect
solution first of all we need access to
our sensitive attributes right in all
cases at least during training but in
the post-processing one even during
prediction and that's going to be a hard
story to tell right in order to be fair
we need to know we need to know your
race or your gender that's that's gonna
be a tough battle but that doesn't mean
that it's not a battle that we should
try to have at some point because not
doing anything because we say we didn't
have to we can't use this it's probably
gonna end up being worse and of course
just because we didn't measure
unfairness doesn't mean that we can
prove that our models are fair right
there are other metrics that we can use
and you might want to look into them
just because your true positive rates is
the same you could still argue that
because false positive rates are
different it's unfair in some way
because you're allowing more unqualified
people one group to go through then of
the other but still it's it's a start
I'm happy to talk to anyone who has
ideas about this and see if we can maybe
do something together but I don't know
that that was my total gladly take any
questions
you